From filming inside of a dormant volcano to
insurance policies that covered kidnapping,
here are some lesser known
facts about 1999's "The Mummy".
The fictional Rick O'Connell and Evelyn Carnahan
certainly deal with more than their share of
plagues and curses in "The Mummy." The crew and
cast of actors including stars Brendan Fraser,
and Rachel Weisz, also dealt with a few plagues
of their own making the film. Filming out in the
desert was no easy task when temperatures often
hit 130 degrees Fahrenheit each morning. Not to
mention, the Moroccan dunes were a cozy home
to a host of creeping, slithering creatures.
"What do you mean bugs? I hate bugs!"
A professional scorpion catcher was even stationed
on the set. Rachel Weisz told The Birmingham Post:
"What is a place like me
doing in a girl like this?"
In an interview with Entertainment Weekly,
Brendan Fraser talked about a particularly
memorable encounter with a poisonous snake:
Sure, "The Mummy" was a fantastical
action-adventure blockbuster movie,
but there were grains of historic truth amid
all that sand. When director Sommers wasn't
busy animating corpses, he called in the help
of noted Egyptologist Doctor Stuart Smith from
UCLA. Since no one today was around over two
thousand years ago to hear how people spoke
ancient Egyptian. So Mummy movie star Arnold
Vosloo, who played the villainous Imhotep,
worked with Doctor Smith to get the dialogue
and the lines as accurate as possible.
Sommers told Cinefantastique:
Vosloo was so committed to making his
character seem realistic and plausible,
he worked for hours into the night, learning lines
phonetically over the phone with Doctor Smith.
"Do-re-mi-fa-so-la-te-doooo!
I am in excellent voice today!"
The crew was just as committed to creating as many
authentic props and sets as possible. Production
designer Allan Cameron made long trips to
the British Museum to find his inspiration.
Cameron said:
Even though "The Mummy" is set in Egypt, filming
for the movie was done in Morocco and London.
The Sahara desert, near the city of Erfoud,
became the background for the desert scenes.
The city of Marrakesh became an excellent stand-in
for 1920s Cairo as it had preserved much of its
traditional architecture. The film crew took down
telephone poles and electrical cables to make the
location appear even more like 1920's Egypt. The
town hall became the Cairo Museum of Antiquities,
which Evelyn promptly destroys in the film.
Marrakesh wasn't the only stand-in for another
city. Those memorable river scenes in "The
Mummy" were filmed on England's Thames River,
and not the Nile. So when Rick shouts out to Beni:
"Hey Beni! Looks to me like you're
on the wrong side of the river!"
He's being more accurate than many might realize!
While it seems impossible now to imagine "The
Mummy" as anything other than a comedy-horror
"hokum" flick, that's not how the film was
initially planned. "The Mummy" went through
over nine years of development, multiple scripts,
and several directors before being turned over to
Stephen Sommers. Previous screen treatments were
contributed by "Innerspace's" Joe Dante, "Night of
the Living Dead's" George Romero, "Hellraiser's"
Clive Barker, and "Shock Wave's'" Alan Ormsby.
The earlier scripts were generally
more straightforward as horror films,
though one script set the mummy in Beverly
Hills, wreaking havoc at a local lab. There
was even a discussion about having "The Mummy"
be more like "The Terminator." Tom Cruise,
Ben Affleck, and other popular male leads at
the time were rumored to be originally offered
the part of Rick O'Connell. None of this
gossip is confirmed, no matter how juicy.
"He's still… he's still…"
"Juicy."
Stephen Sommers was a childhood fan of
the original 1932 Boris Karloff film,
but that classic doesn't share much
with the modern remake. For starters,
no one is confronted by a giant wall of sand.
Movie-goers in the late '90s were desperate for an
action hero that didn't take himself too seriously
and a mummy that embodied a real sense of danger.
Stephen Sommers explained it
this way to Cinefantastique:
Stephen Sommers told Cinefantastique one of the
reasons Brendan Fraser was cast as Rick O'Connell:
"Oh yeah, this just keeps
gettin' better and better."
For the scene in which Rick faces the
hangman's noose, Fraser was only needed
for close-ups. But in volunteering to do more for
the scene, he tells of a complete blacking out.
As Fraser recently recalled the
incident for Entertainment Weekly:
Sommers disputes this version of events,
saying that Fraser "is totally to blame."
"I wouldn't say that."
Nevertheless, the two continue to be
good friends. But the fact remains that
filming was intense. Fraser needed
multiple surgeries — including back
surgery — after filming the first three
films due to injuries and physical strain.
"I am a LIBRARIAN!"
In "The Mummy," Rachel Weisz proved there was
more to a librarian than meets the eye. She did
some of her own stunts, including camel riding,
which despite what her character says on camera…
"I think they're adorable!"
Weisz didn't find them quite so
adorable off-camera. As for stunts,
one that concerned her was not her own,
but one that injured a stuntman during a
gunfight. As she told The Birmingham Post:
Before her role as Evelyn Carnahan in "The Mummy,"
Weisz was still relatively unknown. She
confessed that she had not thought about
doing a big-budget movie before until
she saw the script for "The Mummy."
As she explained to The Mirror:
Oddly enough, after "The Mummy" was a
hit, Playboy invited Rachel Weisz to
model as her librarian character
for the magazine. She declined.
The real-life Imhotep was not a
supervillain. He was a high priest,
an architect, and a physician. Imhotep
designed the Step Pyramid of Djoser,
which is located in Saqqarah. The city of the
dead Hamanaptra, however, is purely fictional.
The fictional version of Imhotep appeared in
Universal's classic 1932 version of "The Mummy,"
Boris Karloff also portrays Imhotep searching
for a modern-day reincarnation of his lost love,
Ankh-esen-amun. It appears that the original
film's writers, John L. Balderston, Nina Wilcox
Putnam, and Richard Schayer relied on ancient
Egyptian mythology and folklore in their work.
Arnold Vosloo is a classically
trained South African actor and
horror fan who appeared in Ridley Scott's "1492:
Conquest of Paradise." Later he played the
lead in two direct-to-video "Darkman" films.
Stephen Sommers recalled
Vosloo's audition for the Mummy:
Vosloo intended to play Imhotep seriously with no
hint of silliness or camp. He wanted
to emphasize the character's romance.
Vosloo told Cinefantastique:
In addition to examining his character's
motivations, Vosloo researched his physical
appearance, including the fact that
Egyptian priests were fully shaven.
Director Stephen Sommers agreed to try it
out and the results spoke for themselves.
Kevin J. O'Connor played the hilariously evil Beni
Gabor, the opportunistic henchman for the mummy.
He had worked with director Stephen Sommers
before, on the action film, "Deep Rising."
O'Connor created many aspects of his character.
He told interviewer Jim Conlan Chats that he
asked the costuming department for pants
that didn't fit. He regretted requesting
open-toed sandals after a wriggling creature
squiggled under the sand on the first day.
One of O'Connor's most popular lines was inspired
by the giant sand wall effect, which none of the
cast had seen yet. Based on a description,
O'Connor came up with this memorable ad-lib:
"I loved the whole sand wall
trick. It was beautiful."
The actor intentionally added the
line to reinforce the impression
of a slimy employee man "kissing up to his boss."
"You see me as God, right, Smithers?"
"Absolutely, sir."
"You'd kneel before me?"
"Boy, would I!"
Beni became a popular character, and even
though he was chewed up by beetles in the
first film. Sommers talked with O'Connor about the
possibility of bringing Beni back for the sequels,
reanimated as a "discombobulated mummy."
In the end, with so much jammed into "The
Mummy Returns" there was no room for Beni
to return to his former spinelessness.
A lot has been learned since Hollywood released
"The Mummy" in 1999. Like Imhotep himself,
there are aspects of his movie that don't
come across as very sensitive in today's
world. The film remains a beloved favorite
for many audiences, but in retrospect,
there appear to be a few bugs in it due to
its portrayals of ancient Egyptian culture
and people of color. Since the movie's release,
several actors have rethought their casting.
Arnold Vosloo told Entertainment Weekly:
Omid Djalili had ideas about playing his role of
Warden Gad Hassan from the beginning. In an effort
to avoid offending audiences, he wondered if he
could play his role in a lighthearted manner even
though that wasn't in the script. He discussed
this with Stephen Sommers during casting.
In an interview he explained:
For this film, they found
a real volcano – at least
a dormant one. Production designer
Allan Cameron was up to the task,
flying to Morocco and heading out to the dunes
of Erfoud where he discovered the volcano.
As Stephen Sommers told Film Scouts:
Over the course of 16 weeks, the crew
built the city of Hamunaptra out in
the desert. These sets were designed to
collapse during the final action scenes.
Interior scenes were filmed in
London's Shepperton Studios.
Imagine being responsible for
the housing, feeding, health,
and safety of over 800 actors, extras, crew
members, and even Tuareg horse riders in the
middle of the desert! And what if the city
wasn't used to handling 800 visitors at once?
As co-producer Patricia Carr explained:
During location filming, producer James, aka
"Jim" Jacks actually took out insurance policies
for kidnapping. According to Brendan
Fraser, the policies were each worth …
"One Million Dollars!"
While that's not exactly loose change, Fraser
expressed some concern over the figure, saying:
"I only gamble with my life, never my money."
Not all the stars had the same insurance.
The insurance coverage for Kevin J. O'Connor,
who played Beni, was for only $50,000.
He wasn't too bothered about it, though.
He joked to producer Jim Jacks:
With a parade of sequels, video games,
a prequel, and an animated series,
"The Mummy" became the last great action-adventure
franchise before the superhero craze. All things
eventually run their course, but you never
know when this mummy will rise again.